ils refusent d'être les grands oubliés
du tram alors que les élus de la
métropole doivent avaliser ce soir un
passage de la ligne b par jean royer un
collectif d'habitants se mobilisent pour
saint pierre des corps ils réclament que
les études promise pour cette troisième
ligne à l'est soit enfin engagés soit
enfin engagé tristan écrit
elle passerait finalement par l'avenue
jean royer plutôt que par le boulevard
béranger le nouveau tracé de la deuxième
ligne de tram suscite les craintes de
ses habitants de saint pierre des corps
réunis en collectif bérenger abandonné
ils redoutent que la ligne 3 ne voit pas
le jour par heure cloud direction saint
pierre des corps on ose espérer que nos
élus ont une responsabilité et suivent
les spécialistes en sachant que de ne
pas passer par le centre le centre
névralgique de tous les transports en
commun de centre-ville et ne pas
alimenter l'est serait une énorme erreur
et donc donc oui peut-être que l'on
pourrait imaginer que noeud pap et ça
passait à bérenger pourrait dire on va
peut-être pas passer à l'est
pour rappel depuis 2018 une ligne de
tram est en projet dans la métropole
tourangelle elle relie chambre et al
arich pour la ligne 3 le trajet
envisagée est saint cyr saint pierre des
corps mais ces corps pop et russien
craignent que le retard pris sur la
ligne actuelle n'engendre encore plus de
retard sur la ligne 3 passer par le
boulevard jean royer va générer de
nouvelles études dont on n'est pas sûr
que les études donnent un avis favorable
donc ça va sa peur et éventuellement
aussi remettre remettre en cause la
ligne 2 même constat du côté de ces
retraités de saint pierre des corps pour
eux cette troisième ligne serait
indispensable et doit être déployée au
plus vite moi le bus j'ai plus en plus
de difficultés à le prendre par contre
le tram c'est de plain pied et on a
moins de problèmes pour le prendre et ce
serait pour louer solution il faut qu'on
arrête de penser
voitures voilà quoi vous avez vu on en
est au niveau climat et il faut qu'on se
déplace autrement en ville ce soir la
métropole va acter le passage de la
ligne 2 par jean royer les membres du
collectif aurait aimé que la ligne 3
sont aussi évoqués